hello and welcome everyone this is ActInfLab
Gueststream number 16.2
it is june 11 2022.
we're here with Mark Solms this is the
second part in our discussion
we had an awesome part one today we are
going to
have a recap on some of the points that
were addressed in the first part
in 16.1 and then we're going to head
into some unexplored territory so Mark
thanks so much for joining for these
sessions and please take it away
thanks daniel glad to be here again
um
i
i was just testing out sharing my screen
a minute ago and it seems as if i'm
incapable of showing you my face and
sharing my screen at the same time
so take a good look at me you're not
going to see me for a while uh here
comes my screen
please god
there we are
great
uh and here comes my pointer
there we are and here's my title
um
the emphasis is on physiological and
philosophical considerations rather than
computational ones
so i'll start with a brief recap
i made a few claims um
and i didn't get to the end of the this
list um
so i will just remind you what those
claims were and then i will pause when i
get to the point that we stopped at last
time which was here that affect is an
extended form of homeostasis
started with the claim which really is
the main claim
of my of my presentation
it is that affect
feeling
is the foundational form of
consciousness and that it is
intrinsically conscious
um i quoted freud
who
more than anyone else uh introduced the
notion into mental science
that
mental processes are not
intrinsically conscious
that much of our cognitive processing
goes on unconsciously
even he made this point
the point that i'm making
which in his words was that it is surely
of the essence of an emotion that we
should be aware of it
that is that it should become known to
consciousness
thus the possibility of the attribute of
unconsciousness would be completely
excluded as emotions feelings and
affects are concerned and i emphasize
the word feelings uh because there's a
whole lot of reasons why some people
claim that there are such things as
unconscious emotions and unconscious
affects this so just to be absolutely
clear what i'm talking about here i'm
talking about feeling
and you can't have an unconscious
feeling in other words you can't have a
feeling that you don't feel so whatever
might be meant by unconscious emotions
and unconscious affects um
that they can't apply to feelings they
can't be unconscious feelings
but uh that might sound like a semantic
point uh just a matter of words that you
can't have a feeling that you don't feel
that's an oxymoron
so i then went on to
set out various reasons empirical ones
uh why
the claim that feelings are
intrinsically conscious
or also has a solid empirical basis
i drew attention to this discovery that
was made in 1949 already
that the
brain mechanisms
for
consciousness itself in other words what
wakes us up
in the morning
and and puts us to sleep at night the
sort of switching on and off of the
lights of consciousness uh that this is
the business of the reticular activating
system the reticular activating system
is the brain system for arousing
consciousness for activating uh cortical
processes and rendering them conscious
i also mentioned the periaqueductal gray
which plays a a
and also it also plays a crucial part in
all of this
together with the reticular activating
system but i'll come back to that later
for now let's just focus on the
reticular activating system to give you
a sense of what i mean by how
these structures
their their intrinsic function
is the switching on of the lights of
consciousness uh i i pointed out that
you can make a lesion or you can suffer
a lesion as small as two cubic
millimeters in size uh in the
parabrachial complex of the reticular
activating system
in other words a lesion the size of a
match head and that is enough in human
beings reliably to obliterate
consciousness entirely
so i was saying
let's look at these structures
if we're wanting to understand something
of the intrinsic consciousness
generating
mechanisms of the brain
and um i made the point
uh that if the cortex
which is where we normally shine our
light in terms of looking for the neural
correlates of consciousness if the
cortex where the seat of consciousness
then there's an easily testable
prediction
which is that if you
have a case in which there is no cortex
then the patient should not be conscious
not so
therefore i showed you one such case uh
this is one
representative example of its type uh
that here is a patient uh born with no
cortex uh the condition is called hydran
encephaly here you see in an mri scan of
her brain
that where cortex should be there is
just cerebrospinal fluid and you see
that her brain stem is perfectly intact
so
on the view that this brainstem area is
where the consciousness is generated
that it doesn't require cortex
this is a critical case
on the brainstem view she should be
conscious
on the cortical view she should not
and here she is and she's conscious as
you can see
she wakes up in the morning she goes to
sleep at night uh in this sense
the the lights are on
but much more interestingly uh she's not
merely blankly awake uh she her her
her wakefulness has a content and the
quality
and the quality that i'm talking about
is affective quality you see how she
responds to her baby brother being
placed on her lap she responds with some
form of pleasure
um and so there's a there's a content to
this mental state and a quality to this
mental state that she's displaying
why that's important is because when we
first learned
in 1949 that the reticular activating
system is prerequisite for all
consciousness that there's no such thing
as cortical consciousness without brain
stem arousal of the cortex though we had
the view that the cortex provides the
qualities and the contents of
consciousness and the reticular
activating system merely provides the
the the quantitative dimension the sort
of level of consciousness so it's as if
this was a power supply as like a
television set needs to be plugged in at
the wall
the the reticular activating system is
the prerequisite sort of booting up
of the system but the television set
itself uh the cortex where the contents
and qualities of consciousness are
processed uh could still be claimed to
be the seat of consciousness and the
reticular activating system merely as a
as a
power source this is why it was
important to point out that this child
is not only conscious in some blank
sense of wakefulness without content and
quality but rather
that she displays affects she's
emotionally responsive to her baby
brother being placed on her lap just as
this child who also has no cortex
is emotionally responsive here you can
see
she's responding with pleasure
to
a stimulus
and this is quite generally the case for
these children has beyond marcus summary
uh of his observations in many many many
such children they express pleasure they
smile they laugh they show aversion and
fussing by arching their backs and
crying
their faces are animated by these
emotional states they build up play
sequences they smile they giggle they
laugh they show great excitement etc etc
etc
um so i've highlighted all of those
words
to show
that these two cases that i just showed
you with no cortex
they are conscious and they are
responsive and in particular they are
emotionally responsive um and on this
i base the claim
that these children
uh
do have a quality uh that they're cut
they do have a consciousness and this
consciousness does have a quality and it
does have content many people are
perplexed as to how this could happen uh
since they have no cortex how how can
they respond to things like their baby
brothers being placed in their laps
and so
i just inserted this slide i don't think
i showed it last time
just to point out that our sensory
end organs here's the example is the eye
same applies to to to the skin and the
and you know to to hearing and taste as
well the the the the uh
optic nerve
projects to the lateral geniculate
and from there to the visual cortex but
not only to the visual cortex it also
projects subcortically
to the superior colliculi of the
midbrain of the brain stem
which is immediately adjacent to the
periaqueductal gray which i said earlier
i was going to mention again
so these children receive information in
the brain stem which is not conscious
it's not cognitively conscious
perception
conscious perception is generated in the
cortex but unconscious sensory
information goes into the brain stem
where it is responded to consciously
by the emotional structures
that that are the main focus
of what i'm talking to you about
now
um of course
many of you
and like many of my colleagues will
reasonably say well how do you know
that there's something it's like to be
those children these might just be
reflexes or instincts uh these these
might be uh the equivalent these kids uh
of philosophical zombies in other words
they look as if they're conscious they
behave as if they're conscious but we
can't know that they're actually
conscious and so last time i tried to
address
this
objection
by drawing attention to what happens in
cases who lose great swathes of their
cortex
and are able because they haven't lost
all of their cortex they are able to
describe to us what it's like to be them
this is one way of getting around the
objection that because these kids have
no cortex and therefore can't
declare their conscious states we can't
be sure that they have conscious states
so i focus first of all on a case who
has a massive lesion of the prefrontal
cortex the reason i did that is because
this is a favorite
part of the cortex for those who claim
the cortex is the seat of consciousness
like the global workspace theorists they
say it all comes together in the
prefrontal lobes all of this information
that's processed in the posterior
cortexes is re-represented or accessed
in the global workspace
and this this is where the sentient
being the subject of the mind comes
about
and
i pointed out last time that if that
were the case then again we have a
falsifiable prediction
a patient who has no prefrontal cortex
like this patient of mine
a patient w
he has no prefrontal cortex
but he has a sliver of language cortex
he if if his sentient being
was was contingent upon
uh the integrity of prefrontal cortex uh
he should not have sentient being
and so i showed you what it's like uh i
talked to him about what it's like to be
him he claims to be consciously aware of
his thoughts i asked him to imagine
something for me to imagine
two dogs and the chicken
to see them in his mind's eye and then i
asked him to count the legs i thought
this would be a reasonable test of
whether he's actually got conscious
mental imagery and please note the
person i'm talking to refers to himself
as i um so he seems to think that he
exists as a sentient being and i ask him
how many legs they are in total if you
have two dogs and one chicken and to my
disappointment he said eight
and when i questioned his answer he
answered he pointed out that in his
mind's eye the dogs had at the chicken
so i thought that was
maybe not a great joke but it certainly
suggested that there was somebody at
home
and i made the point last time
that these patients generally patients
with massive frontal lesions
that this uh tendency to make pure oil
jokes
is is is considered to be a rather a
common
part of the frontal lobe syndrome or the
frontal lobe personality and this is
part of a bigger story that i mentioned
last time which is that these patients
are generally quite
emotionally disinhibited
and why that's important is because
remember what we are considering here is
the question as to whether the feelings
that you saw
in those patients those kids with no
cortex
whether those feelings could be
generated in the brain stem
and the claim of the of of
corticocentric theorists like joe ledoux
for example is that the feelings
literally come about uh when they are
registered or re-represented or labeled
or even named
some people claim uh that it's only once
you um
are able to re-represent this uh this uh
uh these subcortical uh survival uh
circuits uh in uh a
declarative consciousness uh in in
prefrontal lobes that this is literally
what brings the feeling about
and i think it's quite interesting that
these patients who have no prefrontal
cortex
don't have a dearth of feeling which is
what you would expect if the machinery
that brings feelings about is absent
then they shouldn't be able to have
feelings but in fact what is generally
accepted is these patients have an
excess of feelings
there's disinhibited emotionality in
these patients
um my i made much the same argument
about uh
the the other
major cortical area that is associated
uh with the sentient self uh and that is
the insular cortex of course this is
associated above all with the work of
bud craig but has been very widely
accepted uh that the feeling self comes
about um when um
when uh once the state of one's uh
intraceptive uh body uh is is is is uh
re-represented in insular cortex and uh
so again we have a falsifiable
prediction uh if you take a case who has
no insular cortex like this patient of
demarzios
then there should be no sentient self uh
present and
i showed you this interview where di
marzia speaks to him about his sense of
self and the patient is perfectly
adamant that he exists as a self he
speaks about himself as i i you know
and
at the end of this interview ends with
dimarzia saying
you're aware that i'm aware and the
patient b says i'm aware that you're
aware that i'm aware you know all and
and this patient just like my patient w
is not
deficient in emotionality uh in fact uh
all the basic emotions are present
including both bodily affects and
emotional affects and sensory affects
and um
not only that he's also a little too
emotional
and this is a little disinhibited in his
emotionality and this is what we quite
generally see with patients uh with
incident lesions so again it's very hard
to sustain the argument that the self
actually comes
into being
in the cortex
um
now of course those two cases those
examples of their kinds patients with
massive frontal cortical lesions pace of
patients with massive insulin lesions of
course they are
just examples uh but uh the point is the
point i'm making now is that
the
there's lots of cortex left in those
cases
so
the argument is well you know maybe this
the sentient subject
is generated in the remainder of their
cortex and it's a bit of a that's a bit
of a circular argument because remember
you know the the children who have no
cortex um
we're told well how do we know uh that
that they're conscious they can't report
their conscious states i then gave these
two outstanding examples looking at the
areas of cortex that are most bound up
uh
with with a sentient subjectivity
according to cortical theories of
consciousness and uh these patients seem
to have uh intact a sentient
subjectivity but now i'm told well you
know the remainder of the cortex
might be what's what's generating the
consciousness so we can't use only
lesion methods there's no way out of
that armpass and so i then showed you
last time
evidence of a different kind
i showed you what happens if you
stimulate reticular activating system
nuclei
there again there's a there's a an
easily
tested prediction the prediction is that
if these brain stem nuclei the reticular
activating system and periaqueductal
gray as i'm claiming if these are the
structures that generate consciousness
and feeling
then stimulation of these structures
should stimulate conscious feelings
and i showed you that here's a case who
had a deep brain stimulator placed into
the substantia this this part of
her reticular activating system and
within five seconds uh it's it's it it
uh
generated uh it produced a profound
depression
the patient was actually suicidal
she didn't want to live anymore
this is a patient with no psychiatric
history
the the electrode was placed in her
brain stem for the treatment of
parkinson's disease
and and stimulated the wrong nucleus and
that's how this came about
90 seconds after the the stimulator was
switched off
the depressed feeling disappeared and
the patient generously agreed to allow
for further stimulation uh in the
reticular activating system and out of
it and it was only when that particular
nucleus was stimulated
that that she fell into the depression
so this is the kind of evidence and
remember again i'm just giving you
examples
you can stimulate intense affective
states by stimulating reticular
activating nuclei
and periaqueductal gray you get the
greatest intensity and the greatest
variety of efforts from stimulating
there
and you get nothing of the kind from
stimulating cortex
so
this is a different line of evidence
suggesting that feelings are actually
generated
in the upper brain stem and then i
showed you another line of evidence
that was positron emission tomography
of people in intense affective states
here you see
research participants in in states of
sadness here of anger here of happiness
here of fear and in all instances the
activation uh is in the brainstem
and the circuits arising from it the
subcortical circuits arising from it
that's what we see
the cortex
is
by contrast largely deactivated
so this is a further line of evidence
that the
you know an entirely different line of
evidence remember we've got lesion
evidence then we've got deep brain
stimulation evidence here we've got
positron emission imaging uh uh
evidence that the part of the brain
that's generating the feelings
is the part of the brain that switches
on the lights
and this is why i'm claiming that the
basic uh the foundational form of
consciousness and this prerequisite form
is affect affect is the elemental form
of consciousness a further line of
evidence is pharmacological
manipulations
if you tinker with the neuromodulators
that are sourced in these reticular
activating nuclei like for example
noradrenaline
or serotonin or dopamine all of which
are sourced in the reticular activating
system now
serotonin is of course regularly um
pharmacologically manipulated for the
treatment of depression uh dopamine for
the treatment of psychosis uh
noradrenaline for the treatment of
anxiety
noradrenaline is sourced in locus
ceruleas complex serotonin in the reef
nuclei dopamine at least the one that's
important for psychosis in the ventral
tegmental area all of these are parts of
the reticular activating system if if
all that this system did was switch on
blank wakefulness it might be of
interest to anaesthetists uh but
in fact it's it is the main target of
the drugs of psychiatrists uh who are
treating emotional disorders by
manipulating the chemistries
that are the source nuclei for which uh
are in the reticular activating system
so
on the basis of all of that
i argued remember that affect is the
foundational form of consciousness and
it's intrinsically conscious i said that
feelings uh we don't turn not only on
semantic grounds i'm saying that feeling
is the basic form of consciousness the
reason i'm saying that is because the
basic consciousness generating tissues
of the brain the reticular activating
system
which is prerequisite for the activation
of consciousness in cortex and that this
uh that these structures generate
feeling uh that feeling therefore is
prerequisite is foundational for all
forms of consciousness
i then made if
this is a sort of a sidebar um
the reason i went into this third point
um is that namely that the claim that
affect is not synonymous with
interreceptive inference
in other words that it's not just an
interreceptive form of perception
as opposed to the extra receptor forms
which have been the major focus
of consciousness studies over the last
few decades um vision being the main
focus
i'm saying that affect is not
and why i say this is because this is
increasingly being argued um in fact it
was argued by bud craig himself
that affect is just interreceptive
perception
the perception of the state of the own
body
is the equivalent of the perception
of the outside world
in the more
typical form or extraceptive form of
perception that's been equated with
consciousness i made the point that
there's that there's good reason to
believe that affect isn't just a sixth
modality of perception um and uh the
evidence that i presented for that
was
of various kinds uh for example
that there are affects which are clearly
not receptive for example getting a
fright uh was being startled um or
feeling pain when when when when you you
a pin is stuck into your finger these
are all extra receptive
forms of stimulation and yet they arouse
affective responses so
affect clearly is not uniquely
interreceptive and then i also made the
point that there are
many interreceptive perceptual states
which are not affective you can feel
your tummy grumbling or you can
feel your heart beating or you can feel
your
your your lungs expanding these are not
intrinsically affective phenomena so
intraceptive perception can happen
without affect an affect
can happen without interreceptive
perception
so i was trying to draw a line under the
idea that affect is just another
modality of perception
i i i think that by
detaching affect from perception uh
casts some new light on the hard problem
and so that's where i went next uh and i
reminded you
that david chalmers who coined the hard
problem uh
said that
when we look at um functions uh
perceptual functions like vision which
was as i said the model example
derived from the
or grounded upon the assumption
that consciousness is a cortical
phenomenon
cortical vision became the model example
of consciousness this was following
crick's
initiative in the mid-1990s crick's idea
was that if we can if we can identify
the neural correlate of consciousness in
the case of cortical vision then we can
generalize from that uh
by by discerning the mechanism whereby
visual information processing
gets turned into conscious vision in the
cortex by isolating that mechanism
we will be able to uh understand uh the
the the nature and function of
consciousness and chalmers said that
that's not true
you if you if you isolate uh identify
the mechanism
of visual information processing
like this map here does it doesn't tell
you anything about why there's something
it is like to see
and he he used the
well-known knowledge argument of frank
jackson
the story about
about mary the visual neuroscientist who
knows everything about
all of this and i slightly simplify the
story by saying well let's let's imagine
that mary is blind
even though she knows everything about
the functions of cortical vision she
knows everything about the mechanism
whereby visual information is processed
in the cortex because she's blind she
knows nothing about what it is like to
see and if she were to be
gifted
suddenly with a normal
site
then she would learn something
completely new about vision she would
learn what it is like to see red and
blue what blueness and redness etc are
like
none of which is accounted for by this
information um processing flow diagram
and none of what she knew about the
functional mechanisms of cortical vision
that would have prepared her
for what it is like to see in other
words there's other there's there's
something some something else
about visual information processing
other than the sort of things that
mechanistic um
functionalist dissections like this uh
provide us with uh it doesn't this this
mechanistic account doesn't predict what
that there should be anything that it is
like to see and this is the grounds upon
which people like chalmers say
that a mechanistic effect an account of
the functional mechanism of uh
cognitive and perceptual processes it
doesn't tell us anything about um why
there's something it is like to to to to
perform these processes
and this is the essence of the hard
problem
um i said that i thought that
this might be
because they were looking in the wrong
place
that visual perception uh and and and
and all forms of cortical perception um
and uh indeed not only uh perception
with learning and cognition more
generally that this can readily go on
unconsciously
that these are not intrinsically
conscious processes
that it is perfectly possible to see
um and to recognize faces and to read
with comprehension and even to
discriminate colors
these are all uniquely cortical
processes and they can all go on
in the dark as it were in other words
you do not have to be conscious of what
you're perceiving in order to perceive
it
and so this
this costs a rather different light on
thomas's point that all of this
information processing can go on in the
dark um so you know consciousness uh
can't isn't accounted for by our normal
uh functionalized
mechanist mechanistic
way of doing uh cognitive neuroscience
so i was saying well that's because
they're looking at functions like
perception
and functions like learning uh which
dude which are not uh these are not
intrinsically conscious uh processes
um i i i drew your attention to uh this
other statement of chalmers is from his
famous paper in which he says in summary
there is no cognitive function such that
we can say in advance that explanation
of the function will automatically
explain experience and my point was well
that's because they're talking about
cognitive functions
could charmers make the same statement
if we were talking about affective
functions
i'm saying no he could not
i'm saying that we can say in advance
that explanation of the function of
feeling
will automatically explain experience
because the function of feeling is to
feel it's intrinsically conscious
is this is this function
unlike vision
and perception in general and cognition
as a whole none of that is intrinsically
conscious but feeling affective feeling
is intrinsically conscious you could not
understand
the mechanism of affective feeling
if it didn't account for why it feels
like something because that's the whole
bloody point of feeling
so this question
of chalmers is why is the performance of
these functions accompanied by
experience why doesn't all this
information processing go on in the dark
free of any inner feel i'm saying that
that question is perfectly reasonable
when asked of these cognitive functions
which are not intrinsically conscious
that kind of information processing can
go on in the dark free of any inner feel
but that is not true of feeling of
affective feeling and so
uh my claim and this is where we got to
last time this is uh now
i'm now starting with
new arguments
my claim is that if we can identify the
functional mechanism of affect of
affective feeling
then we will
be able to explain why this sort of
information processing doesn't go on in
the dark so i hope that that's clear
that's kind of like my main point
my main point is we've been we've been
looking in the wrong place and we've
been looking to cortical vision and
cortical perceptual and cognitive
processes in general
in order to isolate the neural
correlative consciousness and chalmers
has said well it doesn't work you can
isolate the mechanism whereby this sort
of in these sorts of information
processing goes on and it doesn't tell
you anything about why there is
something it is like
to see etc
and so my argument is yes that's true of
those processes but it's not true of
affect
affect uh the the the remember what i've
said to you in my summary now today
that this is the most concentrated
consciousness generating tissue that
there is the reticular activating system
and periaqueductal gray
is where the lights are switched on um
and that the
you need uh you you can uh
switch those lights off
with as small a lesion as two cubic
millimeters in extent
so this is the place where we should
obviously have been looking in the first
place uh in order to understand
the
to identify the neural correlate of
consciousness and to enter and to
understand its mechanism
and
much more important than that um is the
fact that the kind of consciousness it
generates uh in that namely feeling is
it is it is an intrinsically conscious
mechanism that feeling uh
it wouldn't exist if it wasn't felt
and so unlike vision and and and
learning and cognition in general which
does not re does not have to be felt uh
affect does have to be felt that's the
whole point of affect so i'm saying that
if we could understand the mechanism of
affect in other words the mechanism
whereby feeling comes about
then we might make some progress
with this hard problem of consciousness
so remember
that's how far we got lost time and now
i go on to
and i'm now going to slow down a little
bit because i'm now going to
argue
try to identify what the functional
mechanism of affect is but i thought
perhaps before i do that i should pause
for a moment in case there any questions
arising from my summary of my argument
so far
carry on thank you Mark
okay
thanks
so um
you see i'm saying affect is an extended
form of homeostasis
um
and by the way this is not
my um
argument this is an argument that was
first
uh to my knowledge first introduced by
jacques pancep uh in the 1990s uh
subsequently uh uh
popularized
by antonio de marzio
so i'm just summarizing
my version of what is in fact now a good
25 year old
argument
homeostasis
is probably the most basic biological
mechanism
it's it could be said that homeostasis
is what
enables
living
organisms to resist the second law of
thermodynamics in other words uh it is
what enables them to be living organisms
um they don't just dissipate uh they
remain in an organized form
and
the
basis of this is homeostasis
that
rather than just explore all possible
states
we living things have to remain within
highly specific states
and
these are called the the settling point
or the set point the viable ranges
of the organism
and this applies across multiple
different parameters
let me use
the example of core body temperature
for those of us who think in degrees
celsius you know we have to remain
between 36 and a half and 37 and a half
degrees celsius that's where we need to
be
if we if we deviate too far from that
very narrow range
then we are at risk of dying
and that doesn't apply only to
temperature it applies to
water uh
to oxygen uh to salt to sugar
to blood pressure to all sorts of things
about our our bodies they have to remain
within very narrow ranges that are
viable with the preservation
of our of our living state if we move
outside of those ranges in other words
if we explore all possible uh states uh
then we die
so we
have to work against that dissipative
trend
as i said that is
this entropic trend uh we have to resist
entropy uh and and
and remain within our viable states a
very narrow specific ranges
of
viability across these multiple um
dimensions
of of our physiology
and
this is
why i say that homeostasis
is what keeps us alive
now a deviation from that settling point
then becomes a demand for work
the organism has to do something to
return itself to its viable bounds
and that's the basic mechanism of
homeostasis that's how all of those
autonomic functions i was talking about
earlier
um like core body temperature and blood
blood gas balance and so on that's how
they work uh if you're moving outside of
your range you have to do something to
return yourself into the range that is
what homeostasis is it's the it's the
mechanism that returns us back to our
viable range
now
what i'm saying is that affect is an
extended form of homeostasis and how it
extends homeostasis is that when we move
out of our viable range we feel it
we feel an unpleasant quality
that means i am moving out of my viable
range
and by contrast if you're moving back
towards your viable range you have
pleasurable feeling
this seems to be the basic function of
affect it enables the organism to know
how it's doing in terms of its
organismic viability
so
the organism feels
when it's moving outside of its viable
range as unpleasure which means this is
bad
and it feels moving back towards its
viable range back towards its ideal
settling point as pleasure which means
this is good this predicts my survival
this predicts my demise
so feelings
are rooted in a value system
in other words that there is something
good and there's something bad and what
is good is to survive and as it happens
to reproduce and what is bad is to not
do so this is of course the basic value
system that underwrites
all of life
this is the value system that
underwrites natural selection
so the so feelings uh are rooted in that
value system and what they do is they
enable the organism subjectively the
organism itself to know
whether it's moving out of its viable
bounds in other words whether it's doing
something bad within that value system
or something good within that value
system that's what feelings do
they enable the organism to know
how they are doing within that value
system now why why does this get added
to homeostasis because not all
homeostasis is felt most homeostasis is
entirely autonomic
i was mentioning earlier uh blood
pressure for example when you move out
of your viable range
your heart rate changes
and your the the the your blood vessels
dilate um in order to
um return you to your viable blood
pressure
you don't need to know in fact you do
not know anything about it uh in fact
it's clinically notorious how blood
pressure regulation works uh because you
can be way out of your viable bounds and
know nothing about it
and i'm just using blood pressure as an
example
there are many many many ways in which
your autonomic uh
nervous system maintains you within your
viable bounds without you knowing
anything about it
so why do we need to feel it
uh well the
the what feeling adds
is when you're in a situation of
uncertainty and a situation where you do
not have a readily uh
pre-prepared
reflex which returns you to your viable
bounds so you don't need to feel how
you're doing if you don't have to make
any choices if you have automatic
predictions
which return you by reflex uh like in
the case of of blood pressure regulation
uh to your viable bonds then you you the
sentient being um have no part to play
in the process uh what what
where feeling comes into its own is
where the organism finds itself in a
state of uncertainty for example in a
novel situation for which it's it's uh
innate um
pre-wired as it were reflexes uh have no
have no uh preparedness
um you find yourself in a state of
surprise and uh now what you're going to
do uh the the the if there's no
reflexive
solution available then
feeling enables the organism to make
choices
choices have to be rooted in a value
system there has to be a good choice and
a bad choice otherwise it's random
so
whether you're doing the right thing or
the wrong thing
is
announced to you by how it feels
so this enables voluntary action i
really must emphasize that this enables
you to choose it enables you to decide
for yourself what to do things are
getting worse
so i'm going to change my mind things
are getting better i will stick with
this
policy this is working
so these are not these are not hardwired
these are not innate predictions
these are choices made on the fly by the
organism here and now and they enable
the organism to survive in states of
uncertainty in other words in
unpredicted situations in other words in
novel situations and god knows there are
many of those in life
so
just to put flesh to those bones let me
give you an illustrative example
normally
respiratory control is autonomic resp
you don't need to make any decisions uh
about breathing it just happens
automatically
so you automatically remain within your
viable
bounds in terms of
the ratio of oxygen to carbon dioxide
um
but that's only when the normal
autonomic reflexes
manage the situation because you are in
predictable circumstances
now imagine that you are in a
carbon dioxide filled room
now suddenly you move out of your viable
browns without bounds and breathing
normally normal reflexive uh regulation
uh of the of of your respiratory system
doesn't work uh because ordinary
breathing uh in this in this carbon
dioxide-filled room that is going to
rapidly lead to your demise so now
you've got to do something you've got to
get you've got to you've never been in a
burning building before let alone this
particular one so you have no you have
no uh reflex or instinct no innate
prediction as to what to do so you feel
your way through the situation
and please note at this point
at the point when you find yourself in
this unexpected situation
this is where this is where your need
for oxygen becomes conscious
so this is a very important point
an otherwise autonomic function uh now
becomes a conscious function uh you feel
what we call air hunger
or suffocation alarm
um and you now you move uh about in this
building
uh deciding which way to go remember you
have no you know prior knowledge of what
to do
and it's only on the basis of how it
feels so if for example you go upstairs
and the oxygen supply diminishes
you feel worse
air hunger
if you go downstairs and there there's a
greater provision of oxygen then you
feel better you feel relief from the
suffocation alarm and so the feelings
tell you whether what you're doing is
working or not and so
your choices
are based on feeling and so you are able
to feel your way through this problem
and survive
this is not a small advantage
the ability to survive in unpredicted
environments is an enormous adaptive
advantage and so that we believe is what
the function of feeling is that's why in
this narrow example
uh why respiratory control suddenly
becomes conscious uh that it that it uh
uh dramatically intrudes on
consciousness suddenly your need for
oxygen uh and the purpose of this is to
enable you to calibrate your choices uh
to to to to change your mind uh about
your policy your current policy on the
basis of whether it's working or not uh
the which is which is exactly what
feeling announces for you
in the absence of feeling
you would behave randomly and
one in a million
will do the right thing and that one
will survive and reproduce and the rest
of you
have had it
so this enables us to make choices
within our own lifetimes we don't have
to let natural selection do it within
our own lifetimes
we can adapt to unpredicted situations
of course
once you've done that
you then also can learn from the
experience within your own lifetime and
so the next time you find yourself in a
burning building
you might
on the basis of
of of of learning from experience
you might have somewhat less uncertainty
about what to do
so
again let me just make sure that i'm
getting across my main point because
this is the mechanism of feeling this is
the function of feeling this is what
feeling does
this is why the organism must feel it
now remember what um chalmers had said
uh that you know why doesn't all this
information processing going in the dark
and so on that was built upon an earlier
argument by tom nagle who said an
organism has conscious mental states if
and only if there is something that it's
like to be that organism something it's
like for the organism
then he went on to say if we acknowledge
that a physical theory of mind must
account for the subjective character of
experience we must admit that no
presently available conception gives us
a clue about how this could be done
so this is what i'm trying to do in this
talk i'm trying to give us a clue about
how this could be done as this is
nagel's way of formulating the hard
problem
why and how is there something it's like
to be an organism something it's like
for the organism
my point is that that question
only makes sense in relation to things
like visual information processing which
it does not have to be something it is
like to to see
there does not have to be something it
is like uh to discriminate red for blue
you can do that unconsciously
the cortex can do that automatically
that kind of information processing can
go on in the dark
but would you would charmers even have
asked i mean nagel even have asked this
question
if we were talking about feeling i've
just explained to you what the function
of feeling is
and it makes it kind of absurd to ask
why and how is there something it is
like to be an organism something it's
like for the organism
i hope that you can see what i mean
why
and how there is something it is like to
be an organism something it is like for
the organism
has everything to do with feeling
feeling is is what it is like to be an
organism
how you're doing as an organism how much
longer are you going to remain in
existence as an organism
that's what feeling is like and and and
and this is why and how uh it exists
so if we can get to what the physical
mechanism going back to what to what uh
to what nagel was saying here he said if
we acknowledge that a physical theory of
mind must account for this something at
his likeness
then he's saying we have to admit that
we currently have no clue that i'm
saying it's because we've been looking
in the wrong place
i think if we look to feeling
and we seek a physical theory of feeling
this will account for the subjective
character of experience
and we will make some progress uh this
will provide us some clue about how
we might uh go about solving uh this
heart problem
now um my next point oh so let me pause
at that point uh having said that affect
is an extended form of homeostasis
that's my next claim uh let's see if
anybody wants to argue the toss or make
a comment or ask a question
yeah so Stephen there's no need to raise
hand after each point we'll take any
questions so go for it steven and then
Dave
if you have anything thank you
yeah thank you no really really enjoying
this um i'm i'm interested in this
awareness
that leads to the homeostatic um
sort of correction and if it's where the
awareness is with the actual cells or
organs
struggling in some way to act or enact
upon the surprisal so be that in the
environment
that they're encountering at the
different scales
so this this issue of actually acting or
enacting and when that action and
inaction
can functionally correlate
up the nested hierarchies
then it's those actions or the the
inability to act in the way that cells
would like
that then is becoming the signal
of what or where action is fading
rather than necessarily a signal of
um
that actually contains the information
inherently
in it i wonder what your thoughts would
be on that
yes
i agree if i'm understanding you
correctly i agree with the emphasis on
action
um so i'll slightly run ahead of myself
if i say this
obviously a homeostatic deviation can
also be construed as a prediction error
in other words what your what you're
doing has not led to the outcome that
was expected
and there are two ways of correcting
prediction errors
you can either
you can either change your prediction
or you can change what you're doing in
order to bring about the prediction that
you had originally in other words
when it comes to
when it comes to prediction error you
can either update the prior and have a
posterior prediction or you've got to do
something differently in order to
confirm the prior prediction so that's
where the emphasis is on action
now why this is so important in relation
to homeostasis
is that you can't change your prediction
about what your viable bounds are you
know if you expect to be between 36 and
a half and 37 and a half degrees celsius
on the basis of acting in a certain way
in other words
firing an autonomic reflex
and you then find yourself to be at 39
degrees celsius you can't say okay my
posterior prediction is that by doing
this i'll be 39 degrees celsius because
if you do that you're on the you're
you're rapidly on the road to death
so so the emphasis so the prediction
error has to be corrected um on the
basis of changing your action policy
doing something different in order to
confirm your prior prediction
so so the emphasis is very much on
action when it comes to these
organismic predictions these these
phenotypic um
the viable states for your phenotype
can't be changed
so
uh you you you can't just up you can't
just change your mind about what you
expect will flow from your actions you
have to change your actions in order to
bring about
the expected or preferred state
of your phenotype
thanks can i just add one piece to that
i think that's really helpful is and
also
in terms of like
multiple scales going down to smaller
scales
so for instance if i actually feel heat
in my body and my i
my body might be my cells
are trying to
act to find a better state that can be
seen as
oppressive and claustrophobic if i then
read that
as being me getting into an
uncomfortable state it could also be me
basking in the sun
on a beach you know in the same way that
if i taste something
that's very sour
there's a there's some sort of action at
the cell or the or the organ
level
reacting
to that sourness or that sweetness which
could be like a nice uh confectionary
sweet for a child you know like one of
these gob stoppers or it could be quite
a
a problem so i i think i like what
you're saying with action i'm almost
wondering whether that that action piece
is
um
the inaction is the prediction error in
terms of how it can go up in terms of
these
these nested hierarchies of of physical
scale
yes um so again i must be careful not to
run ahead of myself too much i mean
inevitably you know you must ask
whatever question comes into your mind
at any point but i i i'm aware that as i
go down this list of of of arguments i'm
going to be addressing those points so i
don't want to make all of those
arguments in one go so i will just say
that for now
that that what you've just asked has
first of all a lot to do with the fact
that we have multiple needs
that there's not only one need that they
have to be balanced in relation to each
other and also
very importantly that we're talking
about a predictive hierarchy
that
this is what you're speaking about with
reference to scale uh that what applies
uh at the sensory periphery uh and what
applies uh at the core of the predictive
hierarchy um have different implications
for the way that
that affect works so i'm just saying
those very kind of
vague and abstract things for now and i
hope that the picture will become
clearer as i proceed
thank you Mark
uh yes Dave go for it
yeah i don't know how to state this
clearly um this is some thinking that i
i got into from listening to a very
recent interview you did with um a young
man in another part of cape town
i'm talking about perception
um
and i there i think there and maybe this
has already been done i just haven't run
across the research that there's a
larger framework in which
these
notions of what can be perceived what
can be perceived consciously what is a
sensory modality what we don't call a
sense
it seems that there are on the one hand
uh
conditions we've been calling those
homeostatic conditions
that you can't do anything about
uh your body either adjusts the blood
pressure internally or
it goes haywire but you can't be aware
of it so we don't think about this as
something that we can consciously
perceive and we don't call
the mechanisms that are sensitive to
blood pressure and uh
core temperature and other things
as
matters of sensation that is a
perception matters of consciousness on
the other
side
the other side of the mapping
there are
single
object
uh influences
a a mechanism that is sensitive only to
blood pressure
presents another reason not to call this
a sense um an eye spot just
tells a certain kinds of worms there's
light around here or there isn't light
around here no directionality just it's
daytime or it isn't i'm under the mud or
i'm not under the mud
um
[Music]
whereas even
a little more information more kinds of
information qualify this more as a
sensory modality
and in
things like hearing and vision and smell
we have this very rich many to many
there's many things you can do about
about many things you can do about
a burning smell
and there are many kinds of odors out
there
this is
tie into anything you're you've been
thinking about
yes um
so the first thing that you're touching
on there
is
the fact that uh homeostasis
is only part of the story uh in fact the
the the the
example i gave earlier uh of the of the
person who finds themselves in a carbon
dioxide filled room in a burning
building
they need to maintain
uh their homeostatic blood gas balance
um but there's nothing that their
autonomic nervous system can do about
that they therefore need to turn uh
to
the to action in the outside world so
when i said that the person starts
moving about upstairs and down and then
feels um uh is this working or is this
not is this good or is this bad
that we call allostasis uh it's it's
it's acting in the outside world in
order to return myself to my homeostatic
palms so that's the first thing i just
wanted to make clear i know it's
implicit uh
and i know i'm telling you something
that you know very well but i just want
to make that explicit for for for uh
our participants that um what the
importance of the outside world um for
uh these internal uh bodily states um
the the the the the bridge from
homeostasis to allostasis is how we
conceptualize that so then it moves to
the next point
which is that think about those kids
that i showed you earlier
who have no cortex
and all they're capable of feeling is
their affect and they don't they can't
they can't consciously
think i feel like this about that
in other words they don't know what the
about that is
they they just feel things uh and they
can't include within their consciousness
of the feeling uh what the thing in the
outside world is that contextualizes
that feeling the context doesn't become
conscious only the feeling itself
to be able to extend the feeling onto
the context to be able to say in effect
i feel like this about that
incorporates the context within
that
terrain of uncertainty where one's
navigating the ones palpating the
uncertainty
in order to make choices not only on the
basis of blind feeling but also on the
basis of what kind of object
brings about this change in my feeling
and what kind of object brings about
that for all of that to be incorporated
within the realm of consciousness i
think is a further leap
and clearly another enormous adaptive
advantage so the first leap is just to
be able to feel the consequences of your
actions the second leap is to be able to
picture
as it were uh your
those actions within the sphere of
consciousness uh and uh and in this way
to bring the context into consciousness
and extend the realm
of choices enormously
thank you Mark and i'll just chime in
with a third question so you mentioned
homeostasis is only part of the story
and in the chat brock asked what part of
the story is hormesis
i don't know that word
so a small stress
inducing like some kind of benefit over
the integrated time horizon like
an exercise stress that leads to
improved strength you mentioned
allostasis kind of anticipatory movement
towards a set point but where does um
for example induced stress mild stress
and recovery play into this extended
homeostatic or generalized homeostatic
framework
so um sorry i i didn't understand what
you meant so
you know i think again
when one gives um
an overview of a of it of an argument
like this one always oversimplifies
what one sort of has to simplify and you
know when i say that homeostasis that
you know you always have to
confirm your prior prediction that's not
entirely true there are also ways in
which the the homeostatic range can be
extended uh the homeostatic ranges i
mean like for example um
uh
you know what i was saying about oxygen
um you you could you can if you're a
diver you know you can learn how to how
to hold your breath and how to manage
the stress uh of being out of your
viable blood gas range uh in in a way
that a naive uh a person like like like
i uh
cannot so they are they are
mechanisms uh whereby uh these these
things can in very very narrow limits uh
these things can be changed but i think
the emphasis there has to fall on the
narrow limits ultimately there is there
is an utter limit to your viable range
and
you know this is the driving mechanism
of the story that i'm talking about here
thank you
of course so much more to say and learn
and add but please carry on
thank you
well you can see highlighted on the
screen now my next point and it might
seem like a small point
it might seem like an obvious point
that complex organisms require multiple
homeostats and in fact i've more or less
said this already but i want to make
explicit um and here
is the same slide that you saw a moment
ago where i've just added at the point
that i've now that i'm now making
the the the the importance of this point
is that
we
have multiple needs which must be
categorically distinguished from one
another in other words we can't have a
continuous variable called need
that that variable has to be factorized
across a number of different categories
so let me be clear what i'm talking
about
imagine you have
if we quantify on a continuous
scale
how much deviation there is from where
you need to be
let's say okay i've got um
i've got
six out of ten
um
of first
and i've got four out of ten
of sleepiness
then all i that means i've got a 10 out
of 20 of total need
and so all i need to do is sleep i don't
need to drink
if i if i can generalize from that
little example the the point that i'm
trying to make is that no that's not
true you have to sleep and you have to
drink and you have to eat
and you have to defecate and you have to
breathe you can't just submit all of
these and and bring down the total
number
if you did that you would die
so
uh we we have to recognize that each one
of these needs has to be
met in their own right
um and that means we need to know
we can't just have a total variable
called need we need to know which need
are we talking about and this is why
they have to be treated as categorical
variables in other words this here we're
talking about how much how much water
i'm lacking here we're talking about how
much oxygen i'm lacking here we're
talking about how much sleep i'm lacking
etc
um so that they can be so that the
category of need uh that the organism
finds itself in uh can be addressed uh
appropriately the appropriate category
needs to be addressed
uh and now i know what i'm saying sounds
absolutely obvious
but why it's important
is that it's because of this
because of the point i've just been
making
that hunger feels different from thirst
and thirst feels different from
suffocation alarm and suffocation alarm
feels different from sleepiness and
sleepiness feels different from pain and
so on because each one of these feelings
with the quality of the feeling tells us
which need
is is at issue
and
categorical variables are distinguished
qualitatively
so we're not only talking about valence
goodness or badness
and arousal how much or how little
we're talking also about
qualitative categories
um and i think that's important when we
come
back to the
whole point of what i'm talking about
namely qualia you know namely um the the
qualitative stuff
of um of of what it is like uh to
do anything be anything and that those
those qualitative distinctions it's of
the essence
of consciousness uh that that it is
qualitative it has qualitative
differentiations
it's not just some uh a total
quantitative some total continuous
matter of need it's a matter of
different categories of need which
therefore are different qualities of
need and i think that's important in
terms of understanding what an affect is
an affect is a state of the organism
registered by the organism in other
words it is intrinsically subjective
it has intrinsic value valence goodness
and badness
which has existential consequences for
the organism and in addition to that it
has quality it it is inherent in the
nature of affects uh that they are
qualitatively distinctive from each
other and i hope and i hope that this
very simple functional mechanistic
reasoning that i've given you as to why
that needs to be the case why that must
be the case
um helps to
to make clear why affects take the form
that they do
remember what we're doing here is
addressing
nagel's question about you know why is
there something it is like to be an
organism and how does it come about that
there is something it is like to be an
organism for an organism that something
it is likeness
is not just a valence goodness and
badness but also a qualitatively
differentiated state subjective state of
the organism
so i think that
by
by reducing the mechanism of affect to
these essential features we begin to see
why
it takes the form that it does why it is
and necessarily conscious something in
the sense that i'm the rudimentary sense
that i'm defining consciousness
so that's why this point is important uh
that's why i wanted to make the point
clearly that complex organisms require
multiple categorical homeostats they
need to be treated as categorical
variables they need to therefore be
they need to be qualified
uh each of these different factors of
need
each of these different categories of
have to be qualitatively differentiated
from each other
and this is a
i think the ground zero
of where qualia come from
now i'll go on to my next point
which is that these different categories
of need must be prioritized
again i think this is a this is in a way
an obvious point
but it's but i want to just dwell on it
for a moment uh to to to to
um
draw out some of the some of the
implications of this
i said earlier that
our
autonomic
homeostats
run
well autonomically
most of the time in other words
there are automatic automatized
predictions
which we call reflexes
that are
when the
organism moves out of its viable bounds
then
it fires these reflexes which bring it
back into its viable bounds and then i
told you that
not all of our needs can be dealt with
that way
some of them
as we move outside of the range
of what the
autonomic reflex can achieve
like for
example
in when it comes to thermoregulation
you start to perspire
if you get too hot this is a reflex
you start to breathe more shallowly and
rapidly painting in other words that's a
reflex these are autonomic responses to
overheating then they reach a certain
limit um you know that you that they
they that
they haven't cooled you down adequately
so then you've got to do something
you want to do something like leave the
kitchen
and that is when that is that is uh what
i've just said applies to one of your
multiple homeostats in other words one
of them now requires allostatic action
you now need to do something in the
outside world and clearly you can't do
something in the outside world in
relation to all your needs
simultaneously
so all the time you're sliding you know
your your your your hydration
your water in relation to salt uh
content of your body sliding all the
time it doesn't mean that you're thirsty
all the time uh you're you're burning up
the the sugars in your adipose tissues
all the time that doesn't mean you're
hungry all the time
so the question is you know
what gets prioritized
and there must be some prioritization
because you can't do everything at once
when it comes to voluntary activity in
the outside world you have to prioritize
there's an action bottleneck
and the point i'm making here
is first of all just simply that that
you do have to prioritize and secondly
that what is prioritized is what becomes
conscious
in other words
as i gave in the example
of suffocation alarm
that that business carries on
unconsciously until it becomes
prioritized at that point it forcibly
intrudes on consciousness
my priority now is i need oxygen
and that's what you feel
the other needs this is the the other
point i'm making the other needs don't
disappear
at that point they continue to be
regulated but they are regulated
automatically
so the prioritization of a need
brings that need into the realm of
palpating uncertainty in other words
into the realm of feeling your way
through the problem
and uh the this i think is an important
uh mechan an important part of how of
how feeling works so let me here
remember i said i was going to talk
about the periaqueductal gray
so and i was going to tell you how
this
plays in
as important if not more important role
in the basic machinery of consciousness
of the upper brain stem than the
reticular activating system
the periaqueductal gray
which is just a 14 millimeter long
structure columnar structure around the
central canal of the midbrain
all
of our homeostatic mechanisms in other
words all of the multiple homeostats and
we have many
all of the multiple homeostats all of
them send their residual error signal to
the periaqueductal gray the
periaqueductal gray is like a final
common pathway
of all of these
homeostatic error signals and it seems
that this is where the prioritization
must be must be going on the the the
the the the the determining which of the
current error signals is the most
salient
then gives rise to and this is an
argument i must again make clear this is
not an argument of this is not my own
novel insight
this was a
argued on comparative anatomical grounds
um
by Bjorn Merker uh in in his in his in
in a brilliant paper uh in behavioral
and brain sciences uh so he he
recognized that the periaqueductal grey
together with the superior colliculi
that i showed you earlier
and the midbrain locomotor region they
form what he called a midbrain selection
triangle in other words this is where
the affect the need
that is to be prioritized is selected
and this gives rise to a feeling uh the
feeling being
as in the example that i gave with
suffocation alarm the need that is
prioritized the need that is currently
most salient the need that is going to
now
color your consciousness qualify your
consciousness in terms of its most
rudimentary property in other words the
feeling the affect
what state
what organismic state am i in i'm in a
state of respiratory distress i'm in a
state of suffocation alone that's what i
feel why it's because there this is
where choices need to be made this is
where
the creature needs to feel the the
person
in that example needs to feel their way
through the problem the other needs
remain
but the other needs the non-prioritized
needs
are not raised to the level of feeling
and and i hope it's why
and we need to understand
mechanistically how does all of this
work
and that leads to my next point so
before i go to that next point let me
just pause again in case there are any
comments or questions about this
prioritization function performed by the
periaqueductal gray which is what
determines what affective state you're
going to be in from one moment to the
next in other words which need uh is
which need is going to is going to
qualify your
your affective state
thank you Mark uh Dave then Stephen
yeah i just want to throw out there um
in sylvan tompkins later work that is
after 1970
he came to
um
elevate
reset
to the status of a fundamental emotion
and i think it's very relevant to this
the notion of suddenly shifting from one
conscious
emotion or one conscious activity or
world attitude to another
uh i i i believe uh yuck poncep drew
pretty heavily on tompkins and the
reason that he doesn't cite him in a lot
of detail is that he accepted so much of
it kind of like what you said about uh i
agree almost totally
with um
[Music]
um
oh the the the britisher whose father's
from india i'm sorry i'm blind can i
understand you had a dialogue with him
just a few months ago um am i completely
wrong about it real seth are you talking
about yes thank you
am i completely wrong this just just did
this was thompson did thompson simply
agree no no i agree with that completely
tompkins uh uh the reason that pancetta
doesn't cite him uh or barely ever he
cites him usually
in in in the beginning
of a kind of a
general discussion you know just just to
say this is the tradition i belong to
and then and then carries on building on
on his shoulders i agree with that very
much
thanks
thank you Stephen
yeah i liked uh when you talked about
palpatine uncertainty um and the
salience around that so that that's a
nice term and i think that relates to
like what is going on so to speak
um so what about what's going on and
then now what
happens next and i'm wondering though as
well
um
if
the idea of where which i think is often
left out there's a lot of categorization
of what things are
but where is it happening that makes a
difference
in terms of
how significant
it might be in terms of prioritization
so i was wondering how much
the risk of the awareness
of
some sort of
this equilibrium happens
um could be featured in in this and
maybe that's where the physicalization
um and the spatialization becomes much
more significant than when you're just
dealing with the brain
yes so well um all of these homeostatic
mechanisms of course the the
physiological processes that they
regulate are widely distributed
but the control centers of these
homeostats
are
for the most part uh in the brain stem
broadly defined um and i say broadly
defined because there's some that are in
the medulla oblongata and pons but
there's some that are in the midbrain
there are some that are diencephalic um
for example i mean just mention the most
outstanding example
the hypothalamus is full of homeostatic
control centers
um
but uh you know so the so so
hypothalamus um
circumventricular organs
um the
uh parabrachial complex um the
um
area prostrama
the nucleus solitars
these are all homeostatic control
centers but
of fundamental importance and i i think
it's not sufficiently recognized
although mac has certainly made much of
it
that all of these
nuclei that i have just enumerated
they in turn project to the
periaqueductal gray
the periaqueductal grey is uh
in my view a metahomius metahomeostat
it's sort of the
the the the the this the control center
of the control centers
uh and that the
the essential function there is a
prioritization function what's extreme
and and by being able to physically
locate uh these mechanisms bearing in
mind what where i started i i started my
answer to your question by pointing out
that ultimately these homeostats
regulate physiological processes which
cannot be localized they are distributed
processes part excellence
but the center the control center can be
localized and those control centers are
there are numerous uh ones and they in
turn
they all they all send their residual
error signal to periaqueductal grade
that that is really important now what
that enables us then to do
is to test models like the one that i'm
describing to you what happens uh when
one or another of these individual
homeostatic control centers is legioned
what happens
when the periaqueductal gray as a whole
is lesioned
what happens i might as well just
insert that here
is you get a persistent vegetative state
in other words uh you get that condition
that um magoon and maruzi led us to
believe uh uh
is is is a theoretical possibility in
other words blank wakefulness
remember i said earlier in my summary of
what i said last time i spoke
that the idea that the reticular
activating system
provides merely a quantitative level of
consciousness and not any quality or
content
that that fictional state of affairs of
blank waveforms
the thing that the reticular activating
system was supposed to be producing
which as i've showed you is not the case
because all of those different lines of
evidence that are summarized show that
what the reticular activating system is
producing is anything but
without quality and without content that
this is in fact the foundational form of
the qualities and contents of
consciousness namely the different
affects
if you lesion the periaqueductal gray
then you get that fictional state that
artificial state of blank wakefulness in
other words uh the these patients um
show
they show non-responsive wakefulness
they still have the autonomic sleep
waking cycle in other words they wake up
in the morning and go to sleep at night
like those those hydrant and cephalic
kids that i showed you but unlike those
kids they show no
emotional no affective
no no no response uh
to their situation and no intentionality
either
and so you know that's uh that's what
you would expect uh would occur uh if
the periaqueductal gray is where the
affects are actually being generated
because remember that's what i'm saying
i'm saying that the
prioritization of a of a homeostatic
error signal
is the feeling of that signal it is the
rendering conscious of that signal
and that is what we mean by feeling
something it means now now this need is
not just a need now this need is a drive
now this need
is driving my voluntary behavior and
that is why it becomes conscious because
as i said to you earlier voluntary
behavior can be defined as the making of
choices
as opposed to the executing of
automatized predictions
just to add to uh notes on that when
hearing steven's questions about spatial
localization and how that can refer to
brain localization as well as like in
the peripersonal space it made me think
about how awareness a awareness it could
be without awareness awareness could be
spatially
dislocated or awareness might be a
highly spatialized percept and then the
other note that i wanted to make was um
as a researcher of distributed
physiology in the eu social insect
colony
this extended homeostatic
perspective um
leads to many interesting connections
when we think about extended social
homeostasis as well
but
just two notes and we can carry on
very good points
so you're saying we can carry on meaning
i can carry on
whichever way you'd like to
okay great so i'm now going to move to
my to my next uh my next claim uh which
is which is i see we have half an hour
left so i must i mustn't it's really
quite amazing you know because you are
so generous with giving your speakers
two hours you lull us into a full sense
of security and thinking well i can just
elaborate as much as i want to there's
plenty of time and now we're down to our
last half hour and i've still got three
points to go so i'm going to it's it's
like uh no one goes there anymore it's
too busy
yeah
well i'm
again grateful for the time that you're
giving me so let me move to this point
and this has everything to do
with the relationship between affective
consciousness and cognitive
consciousness i spoke earlier
about i feel like this about that in
other words the incorporating of the
of the cognitive domain within
the sphere of feeling
and so this is the point that i'm making
now
uh this is a a drawing that a diagram
that comes from a paper that i wrote
with carl fristen um and
and and here um
the the important equation is the third
one uh and and here this diagram
basically is just trying to spell out uh
in in in a visual form uh what what the
what these equations are saying so when
i said earlier uh that um
we
have two ways
of
um reducing prediction error uh uh
when a when a prior
prediction does not lead to the sensory
state that's expected
then
we can either change
our perception
in other words we can change
the prediction
or we can change our action
we can do something differently in order
to bring about the prior prediction so
that's what these two equations uh
describe
that we have a generative model
which generates predictions
as to what sensory state will flow from
our actions
and
so here so here there's an action in the
external world
which is predicted to bring about a
certain sensory state
and to the extent that it does not bring
about that sensory state in other words
the the difference uh here is the
prediction error
and of course the prediction error is
then used to update the generative model
uh in order to give rise uh to better
predictions in order to better maintain
your expected sensory states i i need to
emphasize here
because this was not the case in the
early days
of the predictive processing paradigm uh
that that cole fristen and and and his
colleagues uh uh
unleashed upon the world uh century
states do not necessarily mean
extraceptive sensory states and so
in the examples that i've been giving in
this talk so far
that this would be the equivalent of for
example core body temperature or blood
oxygen level um
etc
these uh the
the most important sensory states for
the organism um are its viable states in
terms of its homeostatic uh expectations
so um
please remember that when i speak about
actions in the world uh the world that
we're talking about here uh is the can
be the visceral body uh and it can be
the external world
the body the the Markoff Blanket um
it it it it the the the the body is as
much external uh to
the blanket uh as the external world is
external
of the nervous system
um i think we've got some we're in
somebody's kitchen here which you must
put you you must put your mic whoever is
doing their dishes there
um so so uh what what this uh equation
here which is which is which is uh uh
written in in words here the rate of
change of precision uh which is which is
uh uh omega in the equation
uh the rate of change of precision over
time depends on how much free energy
changes when you change precision this
means that precision will look as if
it's trying to minimize free energy the
rate of this free energy minimization
process is the difference between the
inverse precision
and the sum of squared prediction errors
so that's this equation here uh put into
words and the it's it's foregrounding
the the central role that precision
plays
in minimizing prediction error
so
um
at the the the
i want to be clear that this
is
precision modulation uh is
in physiological terms uh the modulation
of postsynaptic gain
so the message passing going on here
between error signals
and and prediction signals
is modulated
by
posts it's it's the reticular activating
systems modulation of that message
passing so it's the increasing or
decreasing of the gain on the error
signals that's the role of precision
modulation which is just the same thing
as to say that is the role of the
reticular activating system it is
modulating the gain
uh in the message passing
it to speak physiologically
to speak computationally
it is a matter of
increasing or decreasing precision
values attached to the predictions over
the errors
so this so to put it in in into
different uh words
um if things are turning out as expected
that's good
if uncertainty prevails that's bad
so increasing confidence in a prediction
is good in other words increasing
precision in the prediction is good uh
increasing confidence in an error signal
is bad uh in other words uh
the the more uncertainty the more uh you
you you become
clear that things are not turning out as
expected to that extent of course uh
your confidence in your current policy
uh is reduced uh in other words the
precision in your current policy is
reduced and that just is bad so the
goodness and badness the pleasure and
unpleasure function of precision
modulation that i described to you
earlier
is it has this enormously important
contribution to make to the whole of
this mechanism by determining uh the
influence of the error signal over the
predictive model
so
to the extent
that
precision uh is reduced in the error
signal
and thereby confidence is maintained in
the policy
to that extent the error signal will or
will not
have influence
over the parameters
of the of the predictive model
and so this is trying to illustrate the
crucial role that effect plays um in in
in this whole predictive mechanism so
this is the
this is as it were the role of the
reticular activating system of the
modulation of the message passing that
goes on um in the
these are these are as it were
this synaptic transmission mechanisms
and these are post-synaptic modulatory
mechanisms
and so i'm just wanting to link these
formalisms
to the affective role
that the reticular activating system
plays
so
this so just to go back to the statement
here the mechanism of perceptual and
cognitive consciousness is precision
modulation of allostatic prediction
errors in other words it is the it is
the modulation of confidence in a
current policy
in other words uh the the perceived
consequences of a current uh so so as
you as the as the
a particular need is prioritized uh that
need is felt this generates a category
of predictive policies in other words
this is what i will which is what i do
in this situation in this context that i
find myself in this is what i expect the
consequences will be um in other words
these are my expected uh
and and there's an expected precision
attaching to the error signals of course
all the other
domains of need remember what i was
saying earlier here about the needs must
be prioritized the other domains have
monotonous precisions
so the crucial mechanism in terms of
voluntary action is that to use the
phrase that one of you said you liked
earlier um is the palpating of the
uncertainty in other words the palpating
of the precision and the adjustment of
the confidence in the current perceptual
and cognitive in other words the
alistatic aspect
of of what i must do about this need
state because there's a state of
uncertainty that's been prioritized
there there's a changing of one's mind
on the fly
this is what this mechanism
makes possible so it is the affects are
as it were a drive for or a demand
for predictive work
for for mental work
and this
the modulation the palpating of the
confidence in the policy
over the error signals is the predictive
work so demanded so in other words the
work of of updating one's policy of
changing one's mind
it is
all of it
underwritten by the affect of demand so
the affect of demand for predictive work
is
what gives rise to the predictive work
itself which is the palpating of
uncertainties uh in the current policy
and the sensory states that it gives
rise to
and so this is changing your mind in
other words in other words voluntary
action in other words the capacity for
choice and this is the crucial role that
precision modulation plays
in that process
so
um
that's uh oh okay good so
i think let me just pause for a moment
to see if there any questions about that
because i wanted to illustrate it with
the case which i think is going to
pretty much take us uh to to to to the
end of our time so
before i launch into this last case
let's see if anybody has any questions
or comments about that mechanism
i think we'll go to the case and then
there's always so much to unpack with
defining the variables and understanding
what the edges mean and so on but i
think the case is a good way to close
this
okay
so
this is a this is a patient of mine
mr s
and he had a meningioma here
at the base of his frontal lobes it was
an olfactory sheath meningioma um and it
pushed on his optic nerves and as a
result of that um he
his vision was was was impaired
and this is how the tumor came to
attention and it was successfully
surgically resected
now because of its location
in relation in fact to the optic nerves
there was some nervousness on the part
of the surgeon to remove it in its
entirety in fact
he felt it was not possible to remove it
in its entirety so he left a little nub
of the tumor
and uh this regrew and so uh the
the the patient again uh
noticed these visual difficulties uh
returned to the surgeon
and the operation had to be repeated
because of scar tissue the second
operation is always trickier than the
first and unfortunately
in the second operation um there was a
bleed
and that bleed was into the basal
forebrain nuclei small bleed but the
basal forebrain nuclei are crucial
these are
the upper end of the of the
remember i was saying earlier that these
different parts of the
ascending arousal mechanisms of the of
the brain
that they that they are the source
nuclei for these different
neuromodulators and i spoke of dopamine
and noradrenaline and serotonin earlier
well
these nuclei are the source nuclei or or
there are other source nuclei for
acetylcholine here too but these are
very important source nuclei for
acetylcholine now remember all of these
what i was saying earlier about these
these
neuromodulatory systems is that they are
modulating postsynaptic gain which is
just the same thing physiologically as
to say computationally they're
modulating precision that's what they do
they up and down regulate the precision
uh in the message passing and this as i
said earlier
it dictates you know which which
messages are going to are going to be
selected and and which not so it's a cr
it plays a crucially important role uh
does precision modulation um in
cognition and um
and i'm now wanting to show you this
relationship the relationship between
the affective mechanisms that i'm
talking about that is the the affective
functions that are performed
centrally by periaqueductal gray and
then how this gives rise to the
modulation through these arousal systems
of these different neurotransmitter
systems
and i'm going to now show you how this
worked in this case acetylcholine
modulates the confidence in error
signals
and so
let me just quickly tell you a little
bit more about this patient
um he was he was 56 years old
at the time of the second operation
and as a result of the damage to the
basal forebrain nuclei
from the second operation he woke up
from the surgery with a condition called
confabulatory amnesia
so although
the tumor was resected successfully and
the visual problem was was was corrected
he now had this devastating new
condition uh called confabulatory
amnesia
confabulatory amnesia the patient is is
it's not only that they are um amnesic
in other words that they're unable to
remember particularly recent events uh
but there's also quite a
long retrograde extension too in other
words there's quite an impairment of
their retrograde memory too
not only do they have this but they also
are not aware
of their of their memory problems and so
when they draw up um
when they attempt to retrieve
a memory
their the memory that they retrieve is
not the correct one and they don't
realize it's not the correct one and so
uh they have what appear to be false
memories these are the confabulations
they frequently are related um in in in
some semantic sense with the target
memory with the memory that they're
looking for um
there's some semantic relationship
between the memory they find and the one
they're looking for but they can be
grossly mis
misplaced in space and time
and so these are what we call
confabulations and the patient is not
sufficiently critical of these
misrememberings
as a result of the
the damage to these neuromodulatory
mechanisms so
uh this patient mr s just to give you
one example i mean an
extreme example um he uh he had his
operation in johannesburg uh which is in
south africa which is where uh i hail
from but at that at the time
i was living and working in london and
so the surgeon who i knew well sent the
patient to see me to consult me in
london um
because i was doing work with this with
this condition confabulatory amnesia so
the patient arrives in london on a
friday
and comes to me on the monday
and um
and has no idea that he's in london
because of course he doesn't remember
the journey he can't remember anything
from one minute to the next
and so uh i i say something about well
you know the the the the surgeon
whose name was mr miller the surgeon
referred you
to me because of this memory difficulty
that you're having that's why he sent
you to london and he said london uh what
do you mean london and i said yes you
know you're in london you don't realize
it because you don't remember the
journey uh you know that's the whole
point this is the kind of problem that
you're having and um
he denies it he says he's not in london
now it's that so that's the
confabulatory aspect that these patients
in his memory uh he's in johannesburg
and so he believes he is in johannesburg
so i point out to him it was winter
and it was it was snowing outside i
point out to him uh the
the the wintry conditions outside you
never by the way have snow in
johannesburg so i said look out the
window he looks art is absolutely
shocked
but then retorts
no
i know i'm in johannesburg just because
you're eating pizza doesn't mean you're
in italy that's what he says to me so in
other words you know you don't have to
you know you you mustn't overrate the
evidence of your senses
um
and so that's just an extreme example of
what i mean by how how these patients uh
how how
uh how their their amnesia
it's not just a lack of memory it's also
an an excessive confidence uh in the in
the incorrect memories that they draw up
so uh that's the that's the background
and and i saw this man the whole point
of him being referred to me is because i
treat such patients and so i i then saw
him six days a week um if
at the same time in my outpatient clinic
at the royal london hospital
same time same place he came with his
wife to the waiting room
i would then go collect him take him up
to my consulting room uh spend an hour
with him take him back down to the
waiting room and then i would talk to
his wife uh because uh he he he was so
full of uh confabulations i needed to
verify things um in order to get some
sense
of what was going on and there were
certain themes and this is an
interesting thing about these patients
the these confabulatory patients there's
certain themes
uh that returned again and again uh the
patient was an electronic engineer but
but he uh
in reality he was but he thought the
reason he was coming to me frequently he
thought he was coming to me to to
to because i was consulting him about an
electronic problem
and
or otherwise he thought that the two of
us were electronic engineers together
working on some electronic problem
also frequently he thought that he and i
were
in in some sporting team together that
we played rugby together uh or or we we
were in this a rowing team together now
his wife told me he had played rugby uh
at university uh a good 30 years or more
before
and likewise he had he had been a keen
rower but this too was at university
more than 30 years before and so these
are again uh good examples of
confabulations you know the patient
mislocating in space and time
a memory that that
he draws up now
and he has too much confidence in that
he's too too readily um
accepts uh
the
veracity of of the of the products of
his own memory search so that's the
that's the background now on this
particular day that i want to give you a
little snippet of a session from uh he
on this day when i came to the waiting
room he touched the scar on his head the
craniotomy scar on his head and he said
hi doc to me
so this was progress you know for the
first time he was associating me with
medicine
and he was associating me with the
surgical scar on his head and so i
thought this was great progress and so
when we got into my consulting room i
said to him you touched your head when
we met in the waiting room
and he said i think the problem is that
a cartridge is missing we must we just
need the specs what was it a c-49 should
we order it
so i said to him what does a c-49
cartridge do
he says memory it's a memory cartridge a
memory implant oh sorry i should have
mentioned this his wife told me that he
had had dental implants he'd had serious
problems with his teeth
and these had been for many years but
the the these problems had finally been
successfully treated uh by implants uh
teeth implanted into the into the jaws
so when he said
that that c49 cartridge is a memory
cartridge
and that it's a memory implant it
brought that operation that dental
operation to my mind
he said but i never really understood it
in fact i haven't used it for a good
five or six months now it seems we don't
really need it it was all chopped away
by a doctor what's his name dr Solms i
think but it seems i don't really need
it the implants work fine
so i said to him you're aware that
something's wrong with your memory but
and he interrupts me and he says yeah
it's not working a hundred percent but
we don't really need it it was just
missing a few beats the analysis showed
there was some c or c09 missing denise
brought me here to see a doctor what's
his name again dr psalms or something
and he did one of those heart transplant
things so this is referring to another
operation that he'd had
which is clearly also being referred to
here
which was that he had a cardiac
arrhythmia and
so he had a pacemaker fitted a cardiac
pacemaker so he says so he did one of
those heart transplant things and now
it's working fine never misses a beat so
i said to him which is what i actually
thought
i said you're aware that something's
amiss some memories are missing and of
course that's worrying you hope i can
fix it just like those other doctors fix
the problems with your teeth and your
heart but you want it so much that
you're having difficulty accepting that
it's not fixed already
so he goes on and says oh i see yes it's
not working 100
and he touches his head he says i got
knocked on the head went off the field
for a few minutes but it's fine now i
suppose i shouldn't go back on but you
know me i don't like going down so i
asked tim knox tim knox by the way is a
sports physician in south africa he says
so i asked him nurks because i've got
the insurance you know so why not use it
why not go to the best and he said fine
play on
so um
the that's the end of the snippet that i
wanted to show you um by the way oh
before i to show you about that so so
this is a case uh in which due to
damage to one of the precision
modulating nuclei
or sets of nuclei
in this man's case the basal forebrain
nuclei
due to the damage to the acetylcholine
modulating
mechanisms that
that i showed you earlier
he has too much confidence in his
predictions uh and too little confidence
in the he does not up the gain uh on the
arizona say looks i say to him
his predictive model tells him he's in
johannesburg i said to him no you're in
london
look out the window he looks out the
window he sees snow
you know clearly not something that
could possibly be
associated with johannesburg but he
sticks with his prediction he says no i
know i'm in joburg uh just because
you're eating pizza it doesn't mean
you're in italy uh and likewise uh in
the case of the these memory processes
that i showed you in that session
each time uh that he starts to feel uh
the unpleasure uh of the mounting error
signals the mounting the the things are
so just think about it he has
he touches his head he's on the brink of
being aware
that he's he's had a brain operation uh
that the brain operation has resulted in
loss of memory i i hope you can see that
with him saying uh that uh i i he says
we just need to order the specs for this
module that's missing what does the
module do it does memory you know so
touching his head uh speaking about
operations so he's on the he's on the
brink of recognizing that things were
not
as he expected that things are in fact
uh quite different
my point being that this evokes feelings
this is bad this is a this is a panic
inducing situation
and because this man has damage to these
precision modulation mechanisms that
we've been talking about um that he what
he does is he simply up regulates
the or maintains his confidence in his
prediction and in this way maintains
his his emotional equanimity
rather than
allowing the unpleasant uh uh affect to
dominate and the unpleasant unpleasant
effect uh to update um
to to to to upregulate the error signal
uh and
which would which would normally update
the predictive model
so i'm hoping that in this case you can
see something of the role of affect uh
that the role that the
feelings involved in this man's case uh
in relation to uh his predictions uh and
the prediction errors in other words the
cognitive business um of what he
perceives uh and what he believes and
how what he perceives
changes what he believes and the role of
feeling in all of this i thought this
was a succinct case to be able to
illustrate um
illustrate all of that
the because it's only one case i thought
i should just show you some of this
these are
several papers that we've written uh on
showing how uh these
mechanisms work in confabulation uh we
it's not just this one case we were able
to show
that affect regulation uh that that the
confed that confabulation has a wishful
quality in other words it has a down
regulating of error signals quality and
an up-regulating of predictions quality
and we were we were also able to show uh
that by
analysis of transcripts of cases like
this
we studied many cases like this
how the affect actually improves uh with
each confabulation so there's a
increasing negative effect followed by
confabulation uh followed by an
improvement in the affect
so um i see i'm right at the end of my
time
i just want to uh
i don't have time to go into this point
i'm sorry um this is this is not such a
a fundamental point it's just a slightly
different way that i see the predictive
hierarchy um if we if we um
take seriously um that what we're
talking about here
um fundamentally uh we're talking about
homeostatic systems and that the most
important predictions have to do with
maintaining your
the your phenotypic prior preference
distribution that this has implications
for how we conceptualize the predictive
hierarchy but as i say we don't have
time to go into that and then the last
thing is just to say that
these models that we
that i've i've together with my
colleagues derived from the study
of
of the neuroscientific evidence um
on the basis of this well-known uh
statement of of uh
richard feynman's what i can't create i
do not understand uh we we are
trying to instantiate these mechanisms
that are described to you earlier in an
artificial consciousness um i'm working
with a a group of really great
guys
physicists and and computer scientists
and applied mathematicians
and we presented our
uh our preliminary findings a a few
months ago at um uh carl fristan's
theoretical neurobiology
meetings um and so watch the space um we
are we're we are saying that uh if we
have identified the
mechanism uh the causal mechanism where
whereby affects are generated what they
actually do
in relation to
a self-organizing system
then if this really is how affect is
is generated if this really is how it is
caused
then we should be able to instantiate it
uh in a in an artificial system and and
that's what we're what we're trying to
do at the moment
i'm sorry to have rushed at the end um
but
if you'll indulge me i will wait for if
there are any questions
comments um i just wanted to show you my
so this is i'm saying these questions
can be that they look quite different uh
if we look at it through the lens that
i've tried to encourage you to look at
it with me through in other words
through the lens of affect these
questions why and how is this something
it's like to be an organism something
it's like for the organism and questions
like why is the performance of these
functions accompanied by experience this
is thomas's question
why doesn't all this information
processing go on in the dark free of any
in the field i'm saying that these
questions
i've tried to provide you a clue
as to how we might be able to address
them differently
um oh what happened there
i've lost my
oh oh my good
okay
ah there i am yes
how we might be able to address them
differently but get them through this
lens um sorry to have gone on my word i
can't believe i've spoken for two hours
again
but if you'll
if you will allow me i'll be happy to
wait for any further comments and
questions before we end
as as we have actually a whole document
of questions and many questions in the
chat i think it's a perfect place to um
end the live session and whenever the
affordance presents itself we're always
happy to have a dot three the numbers
keep counting and we'll keep hosting the
sessions because this was
very fascinating and i hope people got a
lot out of it and
very tantalizing
thank you so much for inviting me and
apologies for going on for so long and
i really enjoyed
what little interchange we had over
these four hours i really enjoyed thank
you so much
maybe one nice um future
uh event could be picking up on those
last two which are
extremely interesting and important and
then starting with those two with the
dot one and the dot two as prerequisite
and then sharing more about those two um
when the time is right and having that
as more of a full discussion
very good
thank you Mark thank you Stephen Dave
thanks steven thanks steve thanks daniel
peace out
take care
bye
all right thanks everybody for watching
hope you enjoyed that see you later